Jack for anyone interested in studying
the craft of filmmaking what films would
you recommend they sit down and watch
over and over again Wow which films to
study craft well they're so I mean
that's like that's a tough one
but I do think you know we're talking
about well it's important to watch the
films that where you see all the various
aspects of film again cinematography
staging of actors editing sound music
where all of these things are sort of
firing on all cylinders I mean that's
the most practical way rather if you
look at you could if you see a ton if
you watch movies all the time then of
course you can focus on certain movies
that are like more performance based
like if you're interested in performance
and how to create naturalistic almost
documentary style performance then you
could look like you know if looking
farther than someone like Mike Lee and
look at Mike Lee's films which again
there's a lot of them are visually
beautiful but they're all about like
capturing real moments between people
but if you want to understand all the
components of film then you have to
study people who master all of these
areas so they're a handful of people who
are like you know it's a ton of them but
you know obviously Alfred Hitchcock
comes to mind right away
because this was again somebody who had
complete command over the media this
wasn't an actor's director this wasn't a
visual director only like Michael Bay
this was someone who knew how to use
everything so to watch I I say I tell my
students this watch Alfred Hitchcock
from like when he was making films in
England you know like even you can steam
start with the silent films but even if
you start with something like you know
like The Lady Vanishes or the 39 steps
you know which are just as funny and
interesting and visually stunning as
anything you know he made later or any
recent films for that matter if you
watch all Hitchcock you'll be a better
filmmaker like you could sit down watch
a Hitchcock movie a week and you watch
everything and you'll watch you know you
watch you know obviously vertigo and
rear window and notorious and North by
Northwest and psycho and the birds and
and shadow of a doubt and spellbound you
watch all those movies you'll be a
better filmmaker if you watch Scorsese
you know sort of like soup to nuts
watch like say from Mean Streets on and
you take in you know all of his movies
Alice's the variety of movies Alice
doesn't live here anymore and taxi
driver and you know not just his
gangster pictures like Goodfellas and
Casino but you take everything in you
again you learn from somebody who cares
about everything that's going on in the
frame picture and sound everything I
think those two I think Scorsese in
Hitchcock if you're coming in like cold
is a great place to start and then you
can start to realize you know then you
start to see that I mean there's a huge
gamut there's so many filmmakers you
know you can start anywhere you can go
start with Bergman you can start with
Ford you know but I think those two is I
think that's the place to really start
to get a grasp that's where you become
really aware of camera and camera
movement and atmosphere and blocking and
Composition because they're all couched
in very entertaining pieces of cinema
and there they're not so much calling
attention to themselves but they're not
and Wells again and wells for that
matter it's not subtle filmmaking it's
very dynamic filmmaking and that's like
a way of learning when you first see
like the bold strokes and then once you
recognize those things and how they're
how they're being effective they are
then you can start to examine subtler
filmmakers and you can start to
recognize those same techniques being
applied in a much more unobtrusive way
for that matter I think you know it's
crazy it's a difficult question if you
want to include everybody I know it's a
Kurosawa you know okay all right I would
say Hitchcock Scorsese
kirsov watch all those would be a better
filmmaker
you